coming up on Dr K's exotic animal ER
what did you hump on buddy a frisky
tortoise oh you have to turn a slime on
your face on your head undergoes a
stressful surgery
while an unusual chicken case what is
this it's a turkey vulture chicken
proves tough to solve that's frustrating
and a chinchilla in crisis oh bites off
more than she can chew that is new and
different
[Music]
all right
where's my appointment list
this is a tortoise a land animal so I
have a super busy morning today with a
large sulcata tortoise that has a very
large mass on its neck so tortoise
actually honestly intimidates me because
I don't know their medicine as well
tortoise is apparently big
[Music]
I have a personal soft spot for sulcadas
I do have one myself he has a very very
long life span he's very sturdy animal
and he can be kind of a stinker
especially around November through
January he's constantly trying to bust
out of the yard to find
a lava
how are you I'm Dr Kelleher nice to see
you so Bob's here today and he has large
lump on his neck something has pierced
his skin and set up a huge amount of
inflammation and infection what is he
bashing himself on he tries to get up on
wood the owners were kind of embarrassed
to tell me about how this might have
occurred there's a that painter's show
tries to climb yeah okay I know what
they do in their spare time they will
hump anything that is not nailed down or
running too fast I feel your pain
Dr K recommends surgery on Bob in order
to remove the mass on his neck this poor
animal Bob has to be operated on
I'm not going to hurt myself I promise
I appreciate the stool moving work
smarter not harder
owning a sulcata tortoise is a really
big deal they start out as itty bitty
they're about a little bigger than a
quarter when a lot of people first buy
them from the pet store and sometimes
they don't do their homework and realize
that this animal is going to get to be
over 100 pounds and it's going to need
quite a lot of room in their yard to be
properly kept people don't usually flat
out abandon them but they are constantly
calling like zoos and refuge and other
sulcata owners to try to re-home them
what does sea turtles bigger than that
and at least these guys don't SWAT you
in the butt when you're doing it
sea turtles you feel like a stripper
might let me stick a needle in that if I
give him time to just relax
um
that's how he feels about that that's
how he feels about that
sulcatas can be very strong and very
stubborn and if they don't want you to
touch them they will just climb up in
the shell
Dr K needs to draw blood to make sure
Bob is healthy enough to undergo surgery
this afternoon all right it looks like
everyone have like maybe 0.3
you know I'll do what I can
it worked all right well you mangled
that needle yeah he did as long as it's
not my hands
I forgot how strong they were I know
so right here might be possibly a
puncture wound based on him driving his
head into foreign objects around his
enclosure Jesus is the cereal Humper I
bet you any money there's something in
there
so that's the only major surgery I have
to do in the afternoon theoretically the
morning appointments shouldn't probably
go past 12 or 1 or so they'll say what
reality turns out being like Bob will
rest in the boarding area until his
surgery this afternoon
[Music]
in the back room a nine-year-old
chinchilla is rushed in Shelby is
bleeding profusely from her mouth oh my
gosh oh my sweetheart it's all right
anything bleeding profusely from the
mouth is never a good thing
Shelby is a very tiny chinchilla she
could die if she loses too much blood
of blood and mouth
oh
okay that is new and different she's
bitten her tongue or something
Shelby has a large blood clot in her
mouth that means that somewhere in her
mouth there's a lot of bleeding
it looks like oh my God you know that
gnome all I can see is that she's got a
clot of blood in her mouth there I just
don't want to pull a clot loose she's
not actively bleeding but she's pale
right now I think I just want to put her
in oxygen I'm concerned that if I pull
this blood clot loose it could start the
bleeding up again but I need to remove
it because there's also the possibility
that she could choke on this and not be
able to breathe
it fell off okay
oh awesome
Perfect Rose oh my that's gonna be just
a blood clot let me wrapper up a good
for you again good job Tom are you all
right she's lucky she didn't choke on
that clot it's awful big imagine if you
or I like had a blood clot the size of a
grapefruit in your mouth that he would
you know be particularly happy about
that at all oh no fresh blood in there
oh I see see how that first molar is
sticking out there it's gone into the
side of her face right there okay
because I can fix that you see has
happened is she has a molar whatever
cheek teeth that has grown into a Spur
which is digging into the side of her
cheek and causing it to bleed I want to
get these clients in a room and just
talked about what I want to do
hey Joel good she's okay now a little
gruesome I'm just so it's just a blood
clot just looking at that it's like oh
my gosh don't look at it this kind of
thing could clog her Airway but now that
I've gotten that cleared out I can see
that she actually has one of her cheek
teeth that grew and punctured the side
of her of her cheek Dental issues and
chinchilla can be life-threatening it's
something that doesn't go away their
teeth continue to grow and they will
only grow in the same direction they
were already pointed which means this is
going to happen on a regular basis so
she's going to need to be looked at and
have her teeth worked on every few weeks
exactly that's okay
you did the right thing you're here
you've been on top of it you're doing
great I can tell Joel's very nervous and
I know he's very worried about Shelby
he's not usually this quiet he
absolutely didn't do anything to cause
this in fact he saved her life by
getting her in here so quickly all right
let me do this let me um trim that tooth
back okay I'm just concerned because she
looks pale right now I don't want to
stress her anymore let me just go ahead
and get with her okay thank you all
right
she was my girlfriend's chinchilla first
she's had her for about five or six
years she's so tiny and freaking out I
love her she's like part of her family
Dr K will carefully try to remove the
spur from the molar that's digging into
Shelby's cheek
all right take we want to take a break
yep that's a huge chunk that's a whole
tooth I know
this is the little
spur that was poking into her cheek yeah
is there another tooth that's affected
probably like do you feel like I need to
put her under anesthesia to completely
solve the problem my concerns is putting
Shelby under anesthesia that she is
already nine years old she's stressed
and she's lost some blood but the only
way I can address this situation with
the teeth is if I use some sedation what
I'd like to do is give her a break for
like 20 or 30 minutes and I really would
like to put her in her anesthesia so I
can just fully examine the molars okay
so I'm going to call you as soon as
we're done thank you so much we'll take
care of her no problem I'll talk to you
as soon as possible thank you
I'm freaking out I just wanted to be
okay because
you know she's our little our little
Shelby
Shelby will be monitored as she regains
strength
in the front of the clinic a
two-month-old chicken comes in with a
lame leg I'm bringing in a chicken that
I found at um one of the Farms where my
son goes horseback riding had a broken
leg her name is Olga
she's um interesting looking she looks
like a little vulture and hopefully we
can fix her up when I initially heard
lameness in a young chicken a lot of big
scary diseases come to mind however I'm
hoping it could be trauma so we're gonna
definitely make sure we do a really good
physical so we can figure it out hello
again
how are you good good
oh another crazy stray it's a turkey
vulture chicky mixy oh my goodness
that's really lame though so you know my
son has autism and he does hippotherapy
so at the farm there's a million
chickens there even though they've only
had Olga for a few days Diane and her
son have grown extremely attached so no
pressure this one supposedly got stepped
on by a horse
unfortunately this you're a sucker
it's one of these things I do I pick up
all these little stray animals and it
becomes my uh my deed
he will not stand at all
and he actually has a hard time standing
on that one I don't know if it's just
just he just has a hard time
he's eating and drinking right oh yeah
Chowan it was great that Olga's eating
and seems well hydrated and very stable
but the fact that she refuses to put any
weight on that leg really bothers me I
know that Olga means a lot to this
family and so we're gonna do whatever
it's going to take to save her even if
it requires a surgery like amputation is
he too big of a bird to live with one
leg
a case where of the dislocated and I
closed reduced it and it did great so I
think there's hope we got to get an
x-ray to like see what's going on but uh
we'll figure it out let me just finish
the exam because I need to make sure
you're healthy otherwise
sweetheart
okay hold on I'll go
what's his name Olga yeah it has to have
a fitting name for the looks oh yeah I
said he we all know you're a girl I'm so
sorry I hope it's a girl I already have
the one rooster oh yeah I know
she looks so cute oh she looks like a
little vulture I love her so I can steal
her now a few great time and then we'll
be able to make a plan from there three
okay the old guy she looks great
otherwise though happy day all right say
thank you for helping me I really
appreciate it
Olga's owner is 100 committed to saving
her son's therapy chicken even if it
means surgery but we need a diagnosis in
order to be able to really work this up
okay
whatever what is this it's a baronette
chicken oh I know it's really scary I'm
so sorry you're doing really good little
chicken
I'm hoping that's going to take a good
x-ray
that's grit all that white stuff so
they're like little rocks that these
little chickens eat the theory is they
eat them to help them grind their food
in their stomach it's frustrating
because that's exactly where I need to
look at her hip not even more confused
um if I can see the femurs but for
whatever reason the top of the femur the
femoral head in the hip joint they're
they're gone
I can't tell you from this view that's
frustrating
[Music]
reviewing the x-rays Dr thielen is
puzzled as to what could be causing Olga
the chicken's lame leg I'm going to ask
Dr K to help me out because I have no
idea where her hips are and I really
need a second opinion do you have two
seconds
I still don't know why I can't see the
head I have no idea
I took these x-rays the problem is is
the bone density is poor
so I can't
I can't evaluate the
hip these bones aren't too bad of
density when I'm looking at them but
like what's going on here right
Olga's Hips Don't Look broken but
there's definitely something not right
with them femoral head and cross this
bird oh it happens
and Broiler chickens
basically what femoral head necrosis is
is the head of the femur sits in the hip
joint and then it's really supplied by
lots of arteries and veins but for
whatever reason those Arters and veins
stop working as well and that causes the
bone not to get the nutrients it needs
and then it can start to die off
okay I'm so glad I had Dr Kelleher come
look because what we're thinking is
going on is potentially like a genetic
issue have you ever heard of like
femoral necrosis in puppies no
so there's like throw miss or for some
reason there's the formal has don't get
blood supply and then they start to
degenerate it really looks like that's
what's going on in her is because I just
I I can't see the joints and it's just
or the formal head and that's really
bizarre okay so I'm not positive that
this chicken actually has femoral head
necrosis I really need to research it
more but I'm gonna leave it on the table
for now so I get a chance to investigate
but in the meantime I think doing some
Metacam to
um kind of just decrease any kind of
inflammation and just make her feel
better as well as a lot of K dress and
maybe potentially laser therapy we can
try without having to get too aggressive
I'm hoping all right can you do a laser
treatment today do it right now
[Music]
kind of keeping our fingers crossed at
this point hoping that'll work
okay it's okay
I heard from oral heads or a
vascularized and I'm hoping this is
going to help recruit blood vessels to
the side
we're going to send Oklahoma tonight so
she can spend time with her family until
I figure out exactly what's going on
There She Goes she's a good little girl
all right Olga
all right hello friend
let's bring the tortoise up here okay
and we'll start that and then while he's
when we get a strategy of getting him
under there then you and I can start on
shall be there okay that'll work
Dr k plans to examine Shelby's Dental
trouble
while Tom sedates and preps Bob The
Tortoise for surgery a little more
sedate
he's a little more down okay he asked me
but I tapped his front leg and he was
fine let's see how he'll tolerate this
like just on his like his nose doing
anesthesia on large tortoises is always
a little bit tricky they can hold their
breath for an extremely long period of
time up to like 30 minutes and once the
anesthetic is in their system it takes a
long time to get the anesthetic out of
their system oh that smells funny I know
he's actually tolerating it for like I
would actually try to make him a little
bit like goofy back here yeah Goose him
to make him breathe it in
I'm just trying to make sure Bob
breathes in the iso fluorine
at a quicker rate than he normally would
because he pretty good at holding their
breath but then I gotta watch my own
hands so that I don't get my Knuckles
crushed
I'm breathing in buddy
well Tom is working on getting Bob under
anesthesia Kristen and I are going to
work on Shelby
I'm just gonna open her mouth I'm gonna
look inside and see if she's the other
Miller Spurs that are digging into her
cheek or causing any other problems you
know I've not seen something exactly
like this before this is really unusual
breathe it in how's it going over there
so he's getting weaker oh good yeah
her teeth are just such a mess
normally chinchillas molars are lined up
upon one another so that they are
wearing on each other like this with
Shelby her upper molars are actually
leaning out which is causing them as
they wear to dig into the cheek we can
trim back these furs that are causing
the damage but that doesn't fix the
alignment of the molars you can't put
braces on a chinchilla and fix the
alignment you can only trim off the
Spurs once they grow at least she is not
bleeding anymore yep okay I'll be I'll
be right there I'm just finishing with
her
[Music]
trimming Shelby's teeth will reduce the
immediate risk of her teeth digging into
her cheek
s
so for now we've averted the crisis with
Shelby but this little girl is going to
have to come in on a regular basis for
me to take care of her teeth okay okay
okay
let's get the Doppler on him and get him
in surgery he said now I can work on Bob
he's the tortoise going in to have this
mask removed from his neck what we're
going to do on him is we're going to be
taking off this mass and I suspect he
may have gotten punctured by something
that he was pumping on what did you hump
on buddy
anything could have gotten in here then
it could have obsessed this should be
moderately quick procedure
like there
okay I'm gonna just stop because I want
to keep him just deep enough that he
doesn't feel anything but not so deep
that we're here till midnight
ventilating him
well there's the center of it right
there and then there's just a diminous
tissue around it
so what I'm trying to do is get a plane
of dissection down to the really hard
part of the mass where I suspect there
might be
something lodged in there that's causing
all this inflammation
there is what I need to watch out for
there is the jugular
[Music]
my own Factor just went up
like a lot
[Music]
there's a jugular right there
so I would like to get under it I just
want to get the hard part of this mask
out that's like the center I have to be
very careful how I'm dissecting this off
otherwise he could have a tremendous
amount of blood loss more gauze and
Gauze okay
regular you stay there I'll stay here
I am dying I know what's in the middle
of this nonsense
taking any bets
going for wooder wire
I'd say wire from the tire
Dr K suspects that Bob's injury is the
result of humping something in the yard
which may have pierced his neck causing
the inflammation makes me want to go
home and scavenge my yard to make sure
my tortoise can't get into anything
his favorite is plastic watering cans I
think I think I'm okay he has like three
of them in the yard we call him his
Harem so how do you explain that to your
children
we don't talk about it
[Music]
he just retracted his head I've got the
scalpel blade in my hand and we're
cutting into the mass and the jugular
vein is right there
good thing we've got drugs on board
it's a delicate balance keeping Bob at
the right plane of anesthesia we wanted
him not to be able to feel anything but
we also don't want too much anesthetic
in his system that would prolong his
recovery
all right I'm right at the bottom of the
mass my jugular is still safe
going for the big scissors huh I'm going
for big scissors so hard right in the
middle there I'm anxious to see what
exactly was causing all this problem I
just want to make sure everything stays
quiet before I decide to close it up
Mercy that was lung surgery
it's not a pretty sensation I've ever
done but
done
dying to open it huh I know wow you know
I'm just wondering if I'm actually gonna
find it I want to cut into this mass and
see does it look like it was from a
penetrating injury or does it look like
it was from a tumor something that I
need to send out for a histopath but you
can see the track of where it went in
and this white material is is inspicated
pus man that is whatever poked you buddy
I'm going to wood splinter if that
little thing caused all this I'm gonna
be oh there we go
watch now he'll like take forever to
wake up
was that him lifting his head up no down
here so guys
Bob being very swollen around his front
end it's difficult for us to get the
pulse monitor to pick up I'm getting
stressed about this my biggest concern
having any reptile come out of surgery
is them recovering from anesthesia
appropriately and starting to breathe on
their own
oh my God
guys I'm gonna need some help
not being able to pick up the heart is
extremely nerve-wracking
guys
this can't happen this everything went
well through the whole thing I mean
that was not enough blood loss to cause
any problems
I'm pumping bab's legs in and out to
help move air because we want to get all
the anesthetic gases out of his system
so that he'll start breathing on his own
better oh hey
hey ooh mad tortoise coming up
I could take mad
I'm thrilled that Bob is awake but now
that he is awake he is very unhappy and
he is a whole lot of reptile to handle
he cannot bite this and he must breathe
on his own before I yes before we take
that oh he's porn you're gonna have to
take over the head
I'm not kidding
okay there we go okay that's exactly
what I needed is he pulling all right
that's him all right just take it take
take it out I'm gonna take this out
there we go is everybody okay oh you
have a shirt of slime on your face right
on your head awesome here
all right do you guys want to get them
on the table for Less are on here
I will not be happy until you are really
awake and moving around buddy come on
all right I will be right here all right
hey Dr K yes sir do you want him in the
warmth for now maybe a warm room but not
unattended
it's only 84 degrees in there let's take
off my shirt I'll get your Vice tea you
want iced tea yeah sure all right
since reptiles can't regulate their own
heat we moved them into the heat room
here oh he's just talking to himself
are you just talking to yourself yeah
when he's in there sweating it out in
the warm room
it's Tom not me
after a half hour of close monitoring
Bob is regaining strength and recovering
well I think he just wants to be left
alone now probably he's so mad
the tortoise will stay overnight in the
warm room to recover
[Music]
Dr K's first order of business is to
check on Bob the tortoise
yeah he's really like reactive every
time he's like oh awesome
mom was uh slow to come around from
sedation but he's back to his old cranky
self now Bob The Tortoise is doing well
so Dr K begins her rounds with today's
patients I'm going in to see nacho nacho
is a rabbit that's a little over a year
old and nachos had a history of getting
soiled and urine scald rabbit's normal
urine has a pH of nine that means it's
very alkaline it's like lye soap and if
they are not hiking and posturing their
butt to pee away from their body that
urine will collect on their skin and it
can actually burn their skin we call
that urine scald hey how are you you are
absolutely beautiful huh
all right little one little one I know
you're just here for your bottom end but
we gotta start at the top okay
all right that looks good and she might
on the inside have a little nip from the
male rabbit they were in a small area
and it was that night that he nipped her
so I've kept them separate for her to
heal got it that's been a while ago
right that was a couple days ago that I
noticed it rabbits can seem completely
sweet and innocent but they can actually
be quite vicious with each other when
they are protecting their territory
she's got urine soil down the side of
her legs and down here she's got those
nips she got wounded oh my goodness yes
usually rabbit will like position and
Hike their butt up to pee away from
themselves and if she's not hiking her
butt up it could be due to some problem
anywhere along her spine When I See This
wax in the ears that can also be an
indication that there might be some
discomfort with the rear legs because
they use their rear legs to clean wax
out of their ears well my recommendation
be is that we get some x-rays on her to
see if there's something going on and
with her spine or her legs okay and
it'll also let me take a look at her
kidneys and her bladder okay before we
take radiographs I want to shave the
area to get a closer look at the urine
scald it also let me look at this wound
a little more deeply
my goodness Nacho
the Shaving the whole butt I was going
to just because she's kind of she pees
on herself
so I guess in the past she had been
treated for your own sculptures put on
antibiotics but I guess it came back so
we're going to do some x-rays to see
maybe if she has some arthritis and
that's why she's peeing on herself
he doesn't want crazy though
no she felt really crusty I was colder
but I guess that's what I was feeling
was that bloom there
I guess you know Dr Keller had noticed
that so I'm just trying to clean it up
here and then I guess she can assess it
better once we shave it up
for
Nacho's swollen right there too oh honey
I'm sorry
[Music]
not natural
it looks good
seems pretty straight nachos x-rays
don't show any signs of spine trouble
but the wound on her leg is still a big
concern that wound is very exactly I
know now that I see it like
I need to manage that wound okay
that's all right nachos injury is
serious it's a lot worse than I thought
it was it goes deep it's all the way
down to the point where there's muscle
exposed so the only way to close this
wound is to do surgery there you go
nacho just go sit in there I just want
to let you know that when we had her
under for the x-rays and we shaved the
wound where she had gotten bitten that
is wide open to the muscle I mean it's
it's open it's bad
foreign
the rabbit suffered a wound after a
scuffle with another rabbit but the
severity of the injury is much worse
than anticipated
I just want to let you know that when we
had her under for the x-rays and we
shaved the wound where she had gotten
bitten that is wide open to the muscle I
mean it's it's open it's bad
nachos owners have given permission to
take the young rabbit into surgery
the wound on Nacho's leg is about three
inches long it's amazing that there's
not more infection present here because
I can actually see muscle tissue
underneath this you can see it's very
open this is the kind of damage that
bunnies can do to each other
that's kind of nasty wound this bunny is
mostly hair so I'm not surprised mom
didn't notice right away it's okay it
happens
little bunny
my goal is to clean up the edges of the
wound before we stitch nacho up there's
nothing polite about bunnies fighting in
captivity these rabbits can't get out of
each other's space in the wild they can
get away from each other
sweet little bunny can do a lot of
damage probably like five six inches
long there after we're after the fact
that suture pattern will hold tension
well but she's got enough loose skin
there that would be fine as long as the
owner can keep the wound clean not just
should heal nicely in a couple weeks
which one's the bunny again
yeah right
look you made another bunny
pretty much huh
[Music]
I'm dropping Mimi off today she's coming
to stay the weekend while I go out of
town for a couple of days
Amy is a Vietnamese PoBoy Pig who boards
here
on favorites she knows where her room is
her very own room while she's here she's
also going to do her yearly wellness
exam the last time Mimi was in for
boarding Dr thielen instructed the
owners to put Mimi on a diet this time
Dr thielen will make sure she's losing
weight she puts on a couple of extra
pounds during mango season so we've been
trying to walk those off and hopefully
she's gotten down to her her normal
weight
[Music]
thank you
so I'm really bummed I just found out
that Olga's coming back in
yesterday she seems so well and today
she's not using the good lug now
good chicken I know put your feet this
way
so we're trying to weigh Olga and she is
one leg forward one leg back
that's a big red flag for a deadly
disease called Merrick's disease and if
that's the case all goes honors are
going to be heartbroken
my son has autism and um he sees me
bringing the chicken in every morning
and keeps asking me about it so it'd be
hard if I don't come home with her but
um
he's getting used to it so um you know
he has a lot of empathy for everything
hi hey
this morning woke up and uh she doesn't
want to stay in too well on it
so usually homeric starts is they're
just a toxic they're just wobbly but it
definitely can start off as your lateral
process
it's a virus it's caused by type herpes
virus actually so I'm hoping that's not
what she has but
if that's what it is then she definitely
needs to be euthanized I mean this
morning she was on her side she couldn't
get up
and she's eating and drinking but she's
not okay she can't get to her food now
is the point and you know even if it's
not Merrick's I mean if she's declining
she's declining
there's actually not a test for
barrick's disease before the animal dies
it's so we're gonna have to just base
this decision on her quality of life
what does your son think
oh you know every day sees me bring
around you know he saw chicken sick
chicken sick chicken sick
nothing you can do about it
sadly at this point I would do anything
for this chicken
I'm so sorry
good
after a major decline overnight it's
clear that Olga the chicken's condition
cannot be cured
[Music]
I'm so sorry although it's a really
difficult decision after a lot of
thought fans decided that the most
loving thing for Olga is to euthanize
her
you can be with her if you want or if
it's too hard then you don't have to be
you have to just kind of make the you
know the best decision for them and not
be selfish
you're doing great
all right sweetie
[Music]
oh gosh if you need anything thanks no
I would have spent everything for her
but there's just nothing nothing to do
for
Diane getting permission to perform a
necropsy on Olga she of course would
like to know what happened but the
bottom line is she just wants to help
the veterinary community and help me
learn and further my education to help
more chickens
I'm going to try to dissect it all the
way down to her hips because on x-ray
they didn't look like they were there
like is that true or is the X-ray just
weird and I'm also going to be looking
at her sciatic nerves to see if
potentially she has the Merrick's
disease so these the yellow things right
here
um
they're actually testicles so Olga is a
boy
she would have been a rooster which is
kind of funny in hindsight
um and these are her I can't call it a
girl now it's going to be hard to call
it a boy so that was the leg she was the
most lame on you can see the left is
about twice the size of the right
the diameter of the left sciatic is
profoundly bigger than the right there's
no lion
that's almost diagnostic without having
to do a diagnostic test for Merrick's
disease so it seems like the right thing
to do was to euthanize her that's crazy
you can't miss that that is crazy oh my
gosh at least I'll give the owner some
closure oh totally
sorry
okay case closed
it's been five weeks since Bob The
Tortoise had a large mass removed from
his neck
today is Bob's final visit
I just want to kind of get going on Bob
yeah he's already pissed off so well
good you gotta go down right nice and
quick then
I'm excited to see what happens once we
get the bandage off here it could have
healed perfectly and everything gone
right or it could be a complete disaster
totally infected
I think you're gonna be pretty happy
oh good
oh sweet that does look awesome Dr K's
goal is to remove the Staples so Bob's
incision can heal on its own
not gonna be easy
he's going back I'm sorry
oh man that's really in there whose
brilliant idea was to close this with
staples
oh me right not very many tortoises
would have this scar I guess
all right I might sit outside with him
for a little bit yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
that's always the best
keeping Bob in a warm environment will
help the tortoise come out of sedation
but this time Tom chooses to sit with
Bob outside
let me know if you need anything will do
Bob and I have bonded over the past
weeks he's a happy and healthy healing
well and I'm just glad he didn't Crush
my fingers or take a bite out of me Bob
isn't the only returning patient
Shelby the chinchilla is back for a
checkup and to have her teeth trimmed
hey how's it going good I haven't got a
chance to meet you I'm Dr thielen oh how
are you nice to meet you but I've met
your
yes she is well known around here and
she had that
crazy blood clot in her mouth oh and she
brought it in it was it was like gooey
and oh she blew it all over her yeah oh
my goodness that was so scary but it
looks like she's doing well today
hi sweetheart
so after Shelby's Dental scare last time
we want to check the teeth today to make
sure that they're growing appropriately
and they don't need to be trimmed again
[Laughter]
okay sweetheart don't worry please be
okay oh yeah she definitely needs it
was gonna look at the back of her teeth
I'm not even going to torture her awake
because I know I'm gonna have to to trim
that anyways okay I'm going to
anesthetize her I'm going to take the
x-rays of her head that way we're going
to get a really good idea of what's
going on with her two teeth we're going
to trim the incisors for sure that one
tooth that was jabbing into her side I'm
gonna just make sure it's true even if
it's a little bit of overgrowth I'm
gonna trim it
mouths are really really tiny and they
don't open very wide I need to get her
anesthetized so I can see what's going
on
they are so so small that there's like
hardly any room to see let alone work
there we go
let me do it in scissors okay Shelby's
case her dental disease is pretty
Progressive she initially presented for
her teeth over growing and actually
digging into the side of her cheek
causing a big bloody mess
let's close them off and see what that
looks like so I just turned Shelby's
teeth to make sure that they're not
going to be poking into her cheek
anymore however I know chinchillas and
only a little bit of the teeth I can
actually see the most of it's actually
in the school so we need to take an
x-ray to really figure out what's going
on
[Music]
kimchi
oh
Shelby the chinchilla is back for a
teeth trim as well as x-rays to get to
the root of her tooth problem so this is
where her eye would be and then the
problem is here so this is the bandable
it's supposed to just kind of go right
there but it's not so these are the the
roots of some of those teeth and they're
actually poking down underneath her jaw
this looks like a really really painful
mouth so I think pain meds are going to
tremendously help this animal
hop in the carrier
work
it's a really big myth that giving them
like wooden chew toys and like that's
going to help with their teeth and that
might be fun for them but that's wrong
and the Chinchilla's case it has to have
lots and lots of chewing movements so
lots of hay so those Cycles on the teeth
is what wears the teeth down okay hey
she did great she's awake oh she did
great oh she's wide awake
um okay that one tooth totally needed to
be trimmed again so I took off quite a
chunk is that bad the teeth are bad and
they're up here and they're down here
and they actually cause a lot of
inflammation and so if I can knock down
that inflammation it makes her feel so
much better if this doesn't work it's
not the end of the line there's plenty
more we can do okay so I definitely
don't want to not give you hope because
I think that this is really going to
help her all right thank you so much so
welcome we'll try to make the best of
her and keep her comfortable
awesome pet awesome pet
[Music]
all right
hi Bob yeah you can see the they were
healed there I'm just so delighted and
I'm so grateful to her
she saved his life
will he
let you fool with his neck at all the
reason I'm asking is because what I
would want you to do is you warm
compresses on the neck with epsom salts
they're phenomenal from drawing out
swelling okay he does like bats he's
been oh good walking towards the
bathroom for six weeks now and no baths
got it yeah it'll be all right just do
compress that um keep me posted on how
he's doing okay all right yeah they're
the best aren't they yeah
thank you so much all right perfect take
care all right good luck with him okay
and thank you for all your help yeah
you're welcome
we're gonna take them home and give them
a bath
thank you maybe the pabloid pigs here
for boarding but she's also due for
Animal Wellness so that means she's
gonna have to get on that scale yes we
all want to look trim and beautiful but
it's actually more important for pigs
because they get really serious
arthritis when they're heavy
cooperate my job is to lure meaning from
the boarding area to scale to get her to
step up
good girl
Mimi weighs 55 kilograms which equates
to 122 pounds and she lost 6.5 pounds so
that's great for her
Jeremy will join Dr thielen for the
wellness exam before taking Mimi back
home she's a little bit spoiled only
child in the mornings when we don't get
up to 10 to her in time
she will put her snout underneath the
bars on the chairs and just pop them
over until you come out and pay
attention to him yeah she's uh she
definitely has us more trained than we
have her
Mimi is exami hello how's it going Diane
Mimi's Mom isn't able to be here do you
mind if we call Diane she wanted to hear
yeah
so we're going to conference call her in
so she can make sure Mimi's healthy say
hi Mommy
you just almost took a bite out of the
phone yeah right I mean these owners are
like unbelievably dedicated to this pig
hi sweetheart can I pet you yeah
[Music]
you know having a lot of people around
and you know prodding at her she usually
has a limited threshold of how long
she'll put up with you for oh yeah there
come to your bed okay come to your bed
she's letting me listen really good
actually don't get scared don't get
scared don't get scared it's okay honey
baby it's all right it's all right
that's all right she might open for you
so it's not both of us oh yeah I can see
really well now actually yeah it's a
good girl
she looks great guys her heart and lungs
sound good do you have any questions for
me mom I don't
absolutely
healthy Diva Pig self oh of course
bye
[Music]
see you later we love Mimi all right
thank you also she's leaving leaving yes
she's leaving leaving
kind of Carly yeah good girl she jumps
right up in the back seat believe it or
not
motivation of going home I imagine I
guess food too I'm sure we have a
phenomenal set of clients doing whatever
it takes to help their pet get better
and that is why I became a veterinarian
to work with people like that it's
amazing
foreign
[Music]